but as you think about setting yourself
up for success from a talent perspective
from a people perspective because as we
all know it's the people that make a
business
you know when you when you're an
investor you always kind of invest in
the founder first right it's
a team b idea wins over a b team a idea
any day
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
thank you
i'm doing well how about yourself it's
great to be here thanks for having me
it's it's wonderful having you here i'm
i'm so excited to talk about some
different topics but we have to start
with
a really extraordinary one how does a
child go to school seven days a week
how does that how does that happen yeah
that doesn't sound like the uh the
common childhood that i know of
yeah i mean it wasn't certainly my
entire childhood but it uh
it happened because my my parents are
immigrants from the former soviet union
they're from the country georgia
and they grew up speaking all sorts of
languages at home
and so for me i grew up in a household
that spoke georgian russian hebrew and
english pretty much interchangeably
and for a couple years of elementary
school i went to regular school
in the u.s monday through friday and
then on saturdays i went to russian
school
and on sundays i went to hebrew school
so there was a lot of fun and education
has been a big part of my life a
lifelong learner passionate about
education
and uh and probably part of it is
because i went to school for a couple
years seven days a week
that that's just wrong so do you speak
both russian i know you speak hebrew as
well but you also speak russian yeah
i do i do russian and georgian yep so
english russian jordan and hebrew
and that that's just wonderful and
definitely sets you up for for a very
interesting background
but yeah you know other than that you
also
went to harvard business school you were
an investor in vc
chief of staff in a series a company and
now the
co-founder and ceo of learning before we
even
dive into your journey which i which i
can't wait to hear about
talk to me a little bit about what
upskilling is set us up for the second
half of the process
what is upskilling in general
yeah absolutely i i hear the term
upscaling it thrown around a lot and so
for me what i'll share is what i mean
broadly speaking
is the fact that you know a lot of times
when we talk about education
to some extent we talk about where you
went to school you know if someone asked
you about your health you wouldn't say
that i ran a marathon 13 years ago so
where you
learn in school is really just sort of
the beginning right it doesn't end
or begin even really with a degree it's
an entire lifelong journey and so
upskilling is kind of the post-school
learning that you do that's often
on the job often on your own so for me i
had
the flexibility and the ability to take
two years off from the workforce to go
get my mba but a lot of people don't and
it's really really hard to find time to
learn
time is actually the biggest barrier to
learning but upskilling is
as we think about all of the things that
have changed over the last
5 10 15 20 years of course someone over
the course of their career is going to
learn
more over the course of the actual
career than in just that
formal beginning education part so
upskilling is everything that goes
into that lifelong learning piece and
that can apply to everything from
the small snack bites that you learn
from a one-off course to
longer form upskilling as i like to talk
about it where it's
you know one-off courses are not going
to do it for getting you the skills that
you need to succeed in the digital
future
especially when the half-life of skills
is
decreasing as the rate of technology
advances
faster than ever before so just as you
are doing things from
investing to learning to working all at
the same time
the future world of working and learning
will all be kind of
more and more intertwined as you talk
about everything from upskilling to
reskilling continuously over the course
of your life
i think that just fascinating and i
can't wait to hear about how you
actually
help people and employers employees and
employers
resolve the problem of upskilling
through learning but before that yell
take me all the way back to your journey
because it's
it's not a conventional journey by any
means you are
getting your mba at harvard and which
i'm sure it's a phenomenal experience on
its own but walk me through a little bit
your experiences and
and why go from from mba to investor to
chief of staff to co-founder
yeah well i'll start even before the mba
because we started even before with my
seven days of a week of school
so i grew up with education being a
really important part of my life
and i taught and tutored for a decade in
middle high school college to to make
money and so
education has always been a big big part
of my life but as i sort of went into
the professional world
started my career as an investor first
in private equity and then later in
venture but you know had this idea for
how i was going to apply all of my
passion for numbers
and math to the business world and then
found that actually
a lot of what i enjoyed doing was
solving really hard problems and so
found myself
more drawn towards the life of an
operator than that of an investor
but really really truly passionate about
helping people build businesses
across the entire kind of landscape and
spent my two years at hbs
very much at harvard business school
very much focused on how i could
help mission-driven entrepreneurs and
businesses thrive
and so for me it's really important to
be knowing that i'm spending my time
working on something that's worthwhile
that's solving big problems and so a lot
of that is sort of like mission driven
in my mind but it can range from
everything from
food to education to cyber security and
all of the ways that we talk about
ways that we can solve big problems in
society
for me i was privileged enough to be
able to take the time to go to business
school but a lot of people
don't and i encourage people to explore
what it is that they're passionate about
and make space in their own professional
journeys to say
hey you know i have a lot of people
doing a lot of really cool things in my
life
what is it that i want to do what is it
that i am personally passionate about
and where do i want to spend my time
because time is your most valuable
resource
whether you're an entrepreneur or an
individual trying to to make ends meet
and do
everything across the entire kind of
lifelong journey of learning and working
being really really thoughtful about
that is is important and so for me i've
been fortunate enough to have those in
my life who i've considered
formal and informal mentors advisors
who've
been thought partners for me as i've
thought about what journey i wanted to
go on next and so that's helped me
navigate
the the roads between early and late
stage investing and operating
i've done it all and i feel very
fortunate to to now feel
like i'm doing exactly what i'm supposed
to be doing as an entrepreneur i think
that's a
you know when we talk about maslow's
pyramid which is something that i've
been thinking
ever since you know in my sixth grade
hebrew class my teacher showed us the
pyramid of maslow and
and talking about this you know the
enlightened enlightenment
piece at the end where everybody
everybody aspires to and i think that
what you're talking about here is
something that really correlates to that
this idea that
you know you can have your security you
can have your job you can have your
daily life but really if you're
we're aspiring to have that personal
fulfillment it's about also
it's about also exploring our real
passions and thinking okay how can we
integrate them into our work into our
daily life
but talk to me a little bit about you
know this talk to me a little bit about
this this journey with with learning and
how do you even think about before that
even today you said something very
interesting about the half-life
of our of our knowledge and our skills
that the half-life is is
is going down what's happening today in
the 21st century and specifically you
know
starting in 2020 why is the half-life of
our skills going down
yeah i mean there's there's a couple
things in there and and i'd even parse
out you know knowledge from skills
because
as you think about it knowledge
something that you might learn in in a
textbook or in an article or something
like that that's great but how do you
apply it to your life to your work
and being able to actually continuously
develop
new skills learn new things learning to
learn
is a skill in and of itself and so being
able to do that in a
more and dynamic way more regularly is
something that will set people up to
succeed in life
because when you think about the rapid
pace of technology
changing right there's more data than
ever before my undergrad i was
interviewed the other day
didn't i was a math and finance major
they they now have a data science
degree and that's something that's
happened in the last you know 10 years
right
and data science when people talk about
it we're just scratching the surface of
being able to understand what we're
talking about
when people say data they can mean
everything from you know
you might need someone who has a phd in
data science or you might just need to
teach someone who's a business business
analyst and
is a whiz in excel python sql or r those
are very very different skill sets very
different profiles of candidates and you
can learn different
things in different amounts of time
costs different amount in terms of
dollars and time
and so being able to parse out all those
different things of
for both a business and an individual
what is it that i'm trying to solve for
what is it that i actually need to do
and then be able to translate that into
okay so i need the skill set of data
science data engineering data analytics
right data literacy i need to just teach
people what does that mean
data like how do we think about all
these different moving pieces
in a way sets us up for success
as a business and individuals they can
see kind of like these are the areas
that are
adjacent to my skill set right if you
are a software engineer that is focused
more on legacy languages and want to
upscale into more
you know modern frameworks you can do
that in a way that is
you know sets you up for success and
sets your business up for success
and so as we think about all the
different things that are changing
right so the ability to teach yourself
those new skills and to be able to
acquire that knowledge on a regular
basis and then apply it to what you're
doing
is going to be increasingly more
important particularly as that you know
that
that rapid pace of of change continues
to
to increase 100 so how you know
starting with the pain and the problem
today because yeah
i'm convinced i mean you know things the
world is changing rapidly the things
that i thought that are that are crucial
in 2017
and they are so different in 2020 and
already you know when i'm thinking about
the startup that i'll hopefully
create you know in in eight nine months
everybody's asking me michael what are
you gonna be
what's your story gonna be but i'm like
i have no idea because the world is
gonna change
threefold by the time that i'm gonna
have to think of an idea so it's
so so given that what why why is it so
difficult for people to do that now why
do we need
something like learn in from the get-go
yeah i mean i'd say that there's a
couple different slices of the market
that have different pain points
and so a lot of where we spend our time
is in the late stage
enterprise sector of of of the market
and so
startups that are constantly hiring and
constantly need to acquire these new
skills and apply them
day zero right day negative one those
are those are very kind of different
types
of situations but late stage companies
large companies that also have these
really entrenched needs but aren't
necessarily able to
perhaps you know hire the top town the
top of their
from stanford or wherever they still
have a need to fill those
business objectives and they have
internal domain expertise
of individuals who have worked in their
companies for
you know 10 20 30 years and have the
ability to learn and it's just about
putting those pieces together
and so to some extent it's about helping
companies understand
hey you know firing and hiring people is
expensive and it's inefficient
and the zero-sum war for talent is not
going to be sustainable and so
as companies are are coming kind of
coming out of this
this uh this pandemic trying to think
about how they can hit the ground
running
yes there's a lot of stemming the
bleeding right now with a lot of the
business world being turned on its head
and there are all these kind of massive
problems but as you think about setting
yourself up for success
from a talent perspective from a people
perspective because as we all know it's
the people that make a business
you know when you when you're an
investor you always kind of invest in
the founder first right it's
18b idea wins over a btma idea any day
and so being able to do those things
that will be able to
set you up for success in the long run
is something that is very very important
for companies of
all stages to be able to do and so for
late stage companies to some extent it's
really just about equipping them with
the tools that they need
and so that's why we've built features
over i mean hundreds of discovery calls
and and with with all sorts of folks
from l d
learning and development teams to
various teams within hr and people
organizations
being able to say hey like what are your
biggest pain points and how do we solve
them
well you can actually create a like a
business case for
almost inevitably upskilling someone in
your organization
investing in your workforce is almost
inevitably roi positive but
especially in areas for some of these
digital skills right when we talk about
data when we talk about
you know digital marketing any number of
these things and so it's about helping
people understand that
this is a need that they can fill
internally by being able to
invest in these specific targeted groups
of individuals
to put them through these various
upskilling programs that are outcomes
oriented
built for the modern workforce that are
remote online you know
very much focused on skills that are
useful today and then be able to apply
those
and see the benefit of that as a
business rather than needing to
to to hire people externally all the
time and not necessarily
brief the benefits of of a really great
workforce
so what i'm hearing is and i think that
you know i even came with it with a
misconception that i was thinking well
you know if you're a startup and you
need a skill just higher
just hire for that skill tap into you
know the pool of new
new graduates but but i think that what
you're talking about here is that you
have
that you have a range of of these large
late stage enterprises
that are perhaps you know if quite a few
years old and they have quite a few
number of employees and you know the
turnaround there is not that quick and
you have people that have were there
maybe for 10 15 years on a certain scale
and they need to up skill to be to be
more relevant
and and to me now makes perfect sense
you know this company might not
have that quick you know turn around and
add that competitive edge to hire that
next top talent but they have this
incredible pool of
very dedicated people that are already
working for them and if they can
devote resources through a program like
learning they can upskill them to
fit that to fit their new digital needs
of 2020 is that is that about
you know what you're what you're saying
here absolutely
absolutely and so there's all sorts of
organizations like the att workforce
2020 initiative
famously put a billion dollars to work
up skilling the organization
verizon similarly has had these large
like large budgets and so when you think
about it
at t and verizon like you know they're
putting a billion dollars to work
not out of the goodness of their heart
but because it's the right thing to do
for their business
right it's almost inevitably roi
positive and so
offering education as a benefit is one
thing that's become
more and more kind of popular mainstream
in these days and to some extent
yes that's absolutely an roi there right
attracting and retaining top talent
is fantastic and that is definitely
where a lot of the kind of dialogue has
been
but you can even supercharge it that
much more when you think about
all of the different organizations
within hr works with i mean when you
have tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of employees globally
there are inevitably going to be
inefficiencies and so when you can
streamline those things and you can take
spend that's already happening
and make it more efficient right tuition
assistance is something that's been
around
since you know for the last 40 years or
so and it's you know in the us
around the 5 250 mark and that's because
five grand got
went a lot farther in higher ed in the
80s right versus today
and today we're in a world where a lot
of you know changes happen and so it's
not just
universities there's online certificates
boot camps all these kind of new age
types of upskilling programs
there's all sorts of different things
you can do to dynamically upskill your
workforce in a way that is highly highly
aligned to your business outcomes and
objectives
and you can do it in a way using
existing budget that is more efficient
and effective
i have to say that i had this phenomenal
experience with a graduate class at
stanford it was a product management
course taught by professor edison say we
had it we formed a team
and we were five working with target on
on helping them think through some
interesting use cases using deep
learning for the retail and one of the
fascinating things about it was that i
was the only stanford student there
the rest were google amazon and we had
salesforce
these were workers that came in and and
now admit now
and i was thinking to myself like how
can i be the only stanford student here
and and it makes perfect sense because
they had a fantastic time they took that
learning back to the company
the company retained them and and one
other thing that you said that was
fascinating to me
was this idea of learning as a benefit
today you know when we go to the company
we ask for what's our compensation
what's our
dental our healthcare and our 401k and
now we're introducing this
what's our learning right what is that
learning is the benefit is another
way of compensating which i think is
just phenomenal that's so interesting
absolutely by the way we're hiring if
you ever want to come work for us
instead of doing your own thing
so you're doing a phenomenal job
pitching wonderful
so tell me a little bit about about why
you're so passionate about this i mean
i'm getting excited because it makes
sense to me you know that you have this
incredible workforce that we need to
dynamically
upskill all the time and but why leave
such incredible positions that you've
had start a new company
and and why you do that because you know
people say entrepreneurs are crazy so
why are you crazy
uh i'm crazy for all sorts of reasons i
i
i'm personally passionate about you know
a lot of different things big
solving big problems as i mentioned for
me a lot of what i've
had guide my decisions at various points
in time has been
you know essentially taking stock where
i'm at and where it is that i want to be
and what it is that i'm
getting out of my current role and what
it is that i want out of my life and my
career
and so one thing that i'm really
passionate about is helping people find
meaning in their careers find the right
paths for them i'm the go-to person for
a lot of people and trying to figure out
what they should do with their life
career-wise
and i'm also someone who has known that
my like some of my most fulfilling
roles in time has been you know as a as
a math tutor as a hebrew teacher
i loved teaching and tutoring never
thought that i would do that
professionally
and have a ton of respect for those who
do but it's one of those things that
there are very few things that are as
fulfilling as helping someone
reach their potential or get closer to
that or help them learn something or
find some sort of meaning or something
like that so that's something that's
always been
really really driving me from a personal
perspective i mentioned that education
is a big part of my life
my mom is a math professor at the
university of tel aviv for 13 years
she's got a phd in math mathematician
she's brilliant you know
as i think about education you know the
people who have
instilled in me the value of education
have been those that have never stopped
learning you know they're people who
she still every once in a while will
sign up for an edx course and so
there's people with where lifelong
learning is is just part of their innate
being
and i feel very blessed to have that
ingrained in me from
a young age and so as i think about the
different moves that i've i've had in my
career
i've had a lot of guiding horses voices
but a lot of people don't have that a
lot of people
don't know what's available to them and
a lot of people don't know
have a desire to learn but don't know
what would be valuable to them
and so the individual learning journey
is something that i'm really really
passionate about
and then when you think about some of
the parts of the traditional
higher ed landscape particularly in the
u.s there's a lot of kind of
moving pieces that have not been so
great for the industry and there is
a massive student debt crisis that is uh
is something that i also care deeply
about and would love to to solve in all
sorts of ways and so
there's a lot of really smart people
working on a lot of really tough
problems
in that in that space um for me the
slice of the market that i'm really
focused on helping solve is the people
who are working the people who are
hustling the people who
are employed by their employer and have
a desire to upskill themselves
who want to learn who want to advance
their careers you know those are the
people that i want to support
on their lifelong journey and there are
people who the companies almost
inevitably will want to invest in
because that talent is then
you know more loyal to your company they
will want to stay
they will feel more fulfilled you will
get that skill set as a company
and not have to you know on board a new
person and all these different things
and there is a way to kind of create all
these you know synergies by putting
together these different pieces
and i just really really love being able
to solve problems and help people on
their journeys
in terms of what that's meant for my my
personal kind of path making you know
at different points in time i've had
people kind of recommend different
things so
my first move for instance i went from
private equity to a portfolio company of
the fund i was at
i had a couple folks who were mentors
for me saying you know
i think you'd be good at operating i
think it'd be good for you you should
give it a shot and i
you know trusted their their wisdom and
and they were right and so
you know at some point i i went from
thinking business school was going to be
not a good use of my time or money to
thinking you know what this is actually
the perfect thing for me right now
and so i think keeping an open mind and
having different people
you know have share their life
experiences and share their insights and
wisdom is has really helped me
you know when i was in venture i was
thinking you know if i want to invest in
series a companies i should probably go
work in a series a company
and so that's sort of what led me to to
move from from that to a chief of staff
role
and the chief of staff role was a
phenomenal learning experience and
a lot of opportunities to get my hands
dirty in operations partnerships the
areas that i lead for learn in now
but then beyond that kind of understand
what it's like to see the the landscape
from you know the back seat of what a
ceo does and see
this these are all the different moving
pieces that happen this is how decisions
are made in real time
and these are the way that you these are
the ways that you actually have to
to kind of make tough decisions which is
really at the end of the day what
operating is about right you work with
imperfect information
to make decisions to the best of your
ability and surround yourselves with
people who
are ideally smarter than you and amazing
humans where you can kind of
have a have a group of people who are
from diverse backgrounds because that
will almost inevitably make your
decision
that much more well-informed um and be
able to do so in a way that you know
drives everyone together in a in a
mission that is hopefully making the
world a better
place yeah that was wonderful
thank you so so much this was just
incredible
and the most difficult and important
question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
i uh i would have to say tenacious is
one of them
um passionate is probably another
and the last is uh you know
let's just go with positive so i'm
optimistic i love that
i love that yeah thank you very very
much best of luck with learning continue
making a really positive impact
this is just wonderful thank you thank
you wonderful thank you
really appreciate it
you